hello everyone welcome to episode two of
skip rewind last week it was called the
SCP roundup but I figured I heard
something else was using that so pretty
much pick the worst name ever last week
because YouTube rewind key might and
this is nothing like YouTube rewind
anyway so if you don't know already the
purpose of this shoe is just to go
through the videos of mine that you
might have missed this week and do a
little bit of a new segment as to what
is happening in the world of SCP so
first of all let's go through the videos
of mine that you may have missed this
week the first video is SCP 701 the
Hanged king's tragedy pretty good SCP I
thought I'd never actually read this
before I created the document so yeah it
was fun check it out
I hope you like it next pretty much the
most ambitious project I think I've ever
done on this channel SCP 93 red sea
object an hour long and it's not even
completely finished really because I
still have to do the recovered documents
as well but it took a long time that's
why I only have four videos this week
instead of five so check that out if the
red sea object is something that you
want to listen to video number three is
as a lot of classic and that is SCP 87
stairwell very unsettling I actually
have some of my old recordings and not a
few people said to me um that I used
them was like yes of course I used them
I I made them I'm still perfectly happy
with them so yeah my my old SCP 87
recordings are in the still couldn't
find somebody to help me with document
three maybe someday
maybe someday wait about was the third
document and the fourth and final one
this week was SCP 231 special personnel
requirements bit of a risky one because
I decided to include the Scarlet Kings
poem in the video yeah the majority of
people seem to like
but there was there was a few people who
said it was distracting I get that I
know this is something different just
trying to make things fresh and
interesting if you don't try anything
you never find out what works and
doesn't work so yeah if you missed any
lose have a little lesson because I want
as many people as possible to be
watching these okay so it's time for the
very first news segment um well this one
isn't really news but I thought it was
kind of cool it was a guy called Dante
CG created this alternate version of one
seven three now the reason I'm including
this in this video is I think it's
pretty cool like it might be like a
copyright free version of 173 that
anybody can use without fear of being
sued by a zumichito I think his name is
I've probably butchered on him yeah here
it is
I thought it was pretty cool um the next
one is you know there's an en CP game
come on it comes out on the 20th of
December it's called SCP secret
laboratory from what I can find out
about this I haven't got a chance to
play it but it's based on SCP
containment breach made in the Unity
engine which is a bit confusing because
I thought SCP containment breach already
had a unity project but yeah that's from
the developer Hubert ma sucah
Moss Moss again I don't know I don't
know how you say that properly but I'm
gonna include a link the steam store
it's actually on Steam could be
promising
so yeah that's game number one it's
gonna be a lot of games in this video
next we have an SCP board game kama
night this is called the skip from site
19 I'm not sure hi they're gonna sell it
but I think it's gonna be coming in 21
days like they're doing like some really
cool art this was posted to the
subreddit this week s AP 96 as of yet I
can't really find any information on the
game I've only seen the countdown on the
site and some art that was created for
it I think some of the game pieces have
been released too so if you go to EFS 19
comm you can actually subscribe for news
of when it's being released at board
games or your thing I think I might try
FM if I'm not completely skinned I might
try and buy it because that could be
interesting
on the final bit of news I thought was
kind of cool cause somebody has made a
game-based or an SCP three-zero-zero it
but it doesn't look but I haven't played
it either but I've got it installed I'm
gonna be playing it later I've just been
super busy I haven't got a chance to
play any of these games but I'm just a
kiss everybody missed it I'm putting in
this video expect a video maybe a 0 for
9 let's play from me
so playing this because that just looks
like a funny idea but yeah I have
included the link in the description if
you want to go and download this that's
such a ridiculous concept but it's just
good to see games colonized based on
more recent SCPs I think because I think
it's fair to say that the Heritage
collection or older SCPs get a lot more
attention and some of it is deserved
some of it is undeserved
but yeah go check that out so what do
you think about this shoe is it a good
idea does anybody care it's just I
haven't really seen this kind of thing
done in regards to the SCP news so if
it's something you think's useful I'll
certainly keep doing it if not I'll just
remove the new segment of it and just
make it as a you know a catch-up video
for my videos of that week if you did
think it was worthwhile please feel free
to contact me via email if you want to
send me suggestions to include in the
new segment they'll be pretty cool if we
have people actually tell me what they'd
like me to cover and I think that's it
thank you very much for listening and
I'll see you all next week where I'm
gonna hopefully complete the Heritage
Collection so I can move on to different
se piece ok good bye
you